little brown's like talking about his
old like relapse
and i was like i was like you did heroin
and i was like damn our feet are
intertwined
they locked but i want to break up the
story i'll open it up
[Laughter]
yeah it's weird because like our whole
crew like uh chappelle's sober
malik doesn't drink yeah
you're pretty sober like you don't drink
malik doesn't drink
stevie really doesn't do anything um
little brows was recovering like he was
in uh he was an addict
so like you know he came in the green
room like right what do you guys want we
got pills we got this and i'm like
i mean i'm the only one these guys are a
bunch of
nobody quitters a quitter yeah i was
like i'll take all thank you
did you used to drink oh yeah i did
probably you had a problem
yeah you don't drink you're sober i i'm
all
every bad life decision i ever made you
trace it back to booze now i'll smoke
from the time i wake up to the time i go
to sleep
i take edibles i take mushrooms justin
is just the same way yeah i mean you
know i take mushroom like tonight i'm
taking mushrooms and edibles and turning
on the camera
i do that every monday night i take
mushrooms you're doing that i take
edibles
what's this so i take mushrooms i take
edibles i smoke a joint and i turn on my
camera for an hour is that safe damn
is it safe for who
but anyway i mean i'm not going anywhere
so it's safe
it's chilling but it's weird man it's
it's weird i do some weird
like we we read mushrooms
uh because uh i remember we did that we
did your live stream show
yeah he's doing the pill one yeah i take
the i take those pills shrooms
it's just like a pill form i take them
that's true and i'll be taking them
tonight
i'll probably take two grand is it is it
micro dosing or is it the full
not when you take all of them but you
can't you can microwave
i think i'm gonna start micro dosing
micro dosing oh really yeah for your
brain it's like
especially for cts what do you do acid
or mushrooms oh mushrooms man acids
i don't think it's acid scrambles it up
a little differently i don't think you
wanna do it you wanna take like a point
three
you're a big boy i'd take a point five
in the morning the first day you take it
you're going to get high
not crazy high nah not close to
hallucinate not close
you know what i'll tell you what it did
for me it's not really like that that
was just what people painted it to be
right
yeah i i i deal
a little bit with depression right i
don't know about everybody else oh yeah
everybody said that yeah i i i deal a
little bit with depression and the
the micro dosing really helped me
honestly get perspective because i was
like i started to feel better and
it's a little the cbd too and then my
own brain started to be able to go
hey listen man you're the same person
you were yesterday
you just have a different perspective
today because these
whatever it is whatever's in the weeds
the silly billion or cyclop whatever it
is
apparently the when you do the
microdosing of the shrooms it does
something with the
the neurons and the nerves in your brain
where it actually
um enhances like the neurons in your
brain so if you've had a bunch of
concussions yeah supposed to help that
help re-fire those back up dude it just
it literally so like
fighters with really bad ct they're
going to the john hopkins yeah
university and then also the cleveland
clinic institute
and they're giving them micro dosing of
shrooms do you
do any of you deal with any kind of
depression at all no i did
do do you i can't tell like sometimes i
feel like it's just life
it's like yeah it's okay to be sad it's
okay but i'll be like ah [ __ ] your ct
i'm super sad today there's some like
you can feel it where you just feel like
there's no
there's no there's a hole that you're in
that you're just
drowning in and and that's the clinical
depression yeah
this is pretty vocal about it cat
suffering so you know exactly and
there's sometimes
all right
yeah yeah but but the micro dosing has
helped me when i get in those deep
holes to get you out yeah that's good i
think i'm gonna start doing just for pre
preventative reasons yeah yeah mushroom
but but but but the nicotine helps you
right yes
i i really i'm thinking about in the i'm
really thinking about because i'm
talking to somebody i was like you want
to try it
shout out to rogue i brought you up on
rogan so how
the sponsor sponsored this man
you gonna hold it
yeah no that one wasn't right for
are there different um dosings yeah
there's three
six and uh what do you get six these are
six
three three of them at a time yeah and
the first time you took them did you get
sick like did you get lightheaded uh
well yeah because uh
mike catherine our boy mike cathy gave
me some that were like 24 milligrams
so i started with that threw up on my
front lawn from my son
not doing that anymore um and then so i
just dialed it back
so i started with just three and then
after you just build a tolerance mike's
not the kind of guy that would throw up
in the front yard but clench his abs
when he did it so it would help
yeah i mean great ab workout
he he does he gets his from sweden and
they're like i want to say his are like
40 milligrams he has 60 milligrams
which is in these are six that's he does
yeah he like makes fun of this stuff but
that's like when i take 100 milligrams
edible enjoyed is in 2500 i'm like what
is
happening just tolerance it's just you
know it's just tolerance i watched him
eat 2 500 milligrams during a podcast
just that death star
and he was like you ready to go i'm like
are you ready to go
have you talked to him so he moved to
new jersey i talked to joey all the time
yeah uh you know he had his knee
operated on i didn't know he had surgery
yeah yeah um but i talked to him all the
time did he
he did 25 you did what a hundred
y'all both are crazy 25 is this dude
tolerance thing 25
100 but it's like when you were drinking
i'm sure you could drink more than
just the normal let's go yeah was there
by the way did you hit a bottom is that
why you ended up yeah it was after my uh
my bro i lost my brother to uh
prescription drugs
and lost my best friend to heroin and so
i was just like going on a
downward spiral and then i just felt
like i was like kind of like slapping
them in the face
by the way like i was drinking you know
what i mean and then so then i was just
like i gotta [ __ ] stop do you talk
about it on stage
what uh uh slightly i've never i've
never like really
dug into it that deep not yet i mean i'm
sure you have some horrible stories
right oh [ __ ] yeah
those are what people like to hear man
and and they're so relatable like
when i hear people who have stories that
are unique and nothing that anybody else
can be like oh that he sounds like
he sounds like yeah that's what you
should be leaning into like yeah
it makes you don't it shouldn't be your
whole act but if you have things
just the hour of that
but but those kind of stories man yeah i
i think those make you different and
unique you know yeah
and yeah you know it makes people feel
something it's like oh [ __ ] like this
person's human
yeah this person that i look up and
watch on podcasts and [ __ ] and
you almost said look up to but you cut
yourself short yeah
maybe not look up to you
you did that yeah you stopped yourself
you're like i'm not gonna say when
you're
you know a role model for these kids
i'm a great guy
[Laughter]
it's tough when you're rolling and dice
and watching me on youtube
yeah how about that when i get off stage
at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son